good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
as Russian missiles strike Ukraine again
overnight we're live in Kiev we'll also
talk to Ukrainian politician later this
hour
um from Ukraine to its border with
Belarus joined in the studio by the
exiled Belarusian opposition leader
convicted in absentia this week of
treason Plaza's talks continue to try to
ease tensions between unions and the
health secretary joined by the former
Health secretary Stephen Doral to get
his take on whether there's an end in
sight for weather forecast 2 if you're
heading out to work in the white stuff
it's Thursday the 9th of March
Russian missiles strike Ukrainian cities
overnight and the zaparizian nuclear
plant loses power
meters of snow and blizzards in some
parts as the cold blast hits
cashing in Sky News can reveal that
Boris Johnson has earned 85 of all of
the outside earnings generated by MPS
this year how much is that almost 5
million quid
NHS striked stalks rumble on but there
will be a breakthrough potentially we're
told
Of Mice and Men scientists create mice
with two biological fathers what could
it lead to biological babies for
same-sex couples
from master and Miss to prince and
princess Harry and Megan have begun
using Royal titles for their two
children what do you think about that
tackling stigma I'll speak to the rugby
Legend Gareth Thomas about a new
awareness campaign to change perceptions
about HIV
thank you
morning everyone let's start with some
breaking news from overnight should we
Russian missiles have struck cities
right across Ukraine including the
capital Kiev the Black Sea port of
Odessa and the Second City of kharkiv
zaporizia nuclear plant has lost power
our chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
joins us now from Kiev uh Stuart good
morning what's happening
well it's been about three weeks since
we've seen this type of thing it's a big
attack
um at least two explosions here in in
Cubes but in other cities as well I I in
one of one has had apparently 15
different uh hits there's always a
slight confusion because it can be the
air defense system uh that is bringing
down incoming missiles so that can
create a feeling of more attacks but
actually sometimes it's just the defense
we know that some residential areas have
been hit as well and of course this
power plant now that can keep going it's
been cut off the grid basically so it's
it's it's some of the reactors are being
closed down but it it still has power
but it only has power for another 10
days or so from its generators so
they'll be working on that immediately
but let's say we've seen this before the
Russians go after energy infrastructure
across the country and that's been going
on for months now but there has been
quite a gap to the last few weeks
uh indeed so and it's alarming that this
nuclear power plant has been taken out
again what happens when when that's the
case
well obviously it you know that and all
nuclear power plants have to have a
continuous supply of energy to keep the
reactors cool and working properly and
yes it has been at the center of a storm
for a long time as to who's in control
of it and and uh whether it's being
attacked or or as actually as the
Russians have been accused of attacking
uh Ukraine from it
um what is as I was saying it's the
um the grid that it's been cut off from
so it's the attacks on if you like uh
the Ukraine free Ukraine if you like as
opposed to the Russian controlled parts
of the country and because it's been cut
off from that they now kicking with
their generators as I say they can last
uh I think there's 19 of those diesel
generators and they can keep going for
about another 10 days as the authorities
here said that so the countdown clock
starts uh straight away but they will be
attempting to get that power back on as
soon as they can okay and just while we
have you Stuart a an overview if you
would please about the situation in
Ukraine at the moment
well there's this fight you're going on
along this hole of the uh front line 600
miles but uh it's that we've been
looking at really closely
um has become a symbol the Russians want
to take it claim victory there for the
first time in about six months and
ukrainians at the moment at least are
saying they're determined uh to hold on
to it again symbolically to show that
their Defiance there was some suggestion
that the government might withdraw its
forces but they've said no to that in
the last day or so and that they're
sending more troops there terrible
battle going on there okay you know huge
numbers of soldiers are dying every
single day and it goes on there seems to
they seem to be a stalemate somewhat
this morning there is a sense that the
Russians have the upper hand but the
ukrainians are putting in more men all
the time and this what they call the
meat grinder is going to carry on
killing people for certain okay Stuart
van I thank you live in care for us this
morning around 8 30 joined by the exiled
Belarusian opposition leader convicted
in absentia this week of treason and
sentenced to 15 years in jail a husband
in jail for 18 years after she lost the
attempt to win the election in 2020.
the UK cold snap is expected to worsen
for many today with more snow more snow
predicted across large Parts bringing
the threat of power cuts and also travel
delays let's get more should release a
standing by for us in Derbyshire this
morning oh goodness it's a very blowy
way you are no snow here in London we
were it was predicted here but a lot in
other parts of the country
[Applause]
well we are in the highest Market town
in England so if it's predicted to snow
it usually snows here
um and we made the trip along the a515
between Ashbourne and Buxton just on the
edge of the Peak District it can be very
treacherous in the snow it wasn't too
bad early this morning but that could
well change this afternoon because we
are expecting for some parts up to 40
centimeters of snow snow storms and
blizzards as well stretching from the
north of the Midlands area kind of the
Stoke-on-Trent area going right up to
the Northeast and Durham as well and
it's this Amber weather warning that
people are worried about expecting
significant disruption particularly on
the road so if people do have an
essential journey to make then people
have been told they need to be prepared
to have proper clothing in their cars
food and drink and some means of
charging their phone up as well it's
cold it was minus one here last night
um just when we thought it was was
entering spring we saw temperatures of
minus 15 in Scotland on Tuesday night so
it would be nice to see a bit of warmer
weather and some sunshine soon wouldn't
it but we could see this snow continuing
through to Friday
okay thank you
taking a look at these uh spectacular
pictures from yesterday here we go how
cool is that wow farmers in the Shetland
Islands recorded what's known as a snow
devil which form when winds pick up snow
into a Vortex it's a little bit like a
hurricane what's it no what's it called
when a tornado there you go a snow
tornado it says that was spotted when
they were out feeding their sheep no one
injured thankfully
now it's time to get your view on a
story making headlines this morning
um we have been asking you uh all week
to offer your views via Twitter we were
asking about whether Boris Johnson's Dad
should be a knight or not today
I'm sure this is going to divide opinion
one foot in one foot uh out it's the
sussexes again Prince Harry and Megan's
daughter lillibet has been named a
princess
what do you think about that after they
separated from the royal family and
moved to the US after all the disputes
certain front pages now they've accepted
the title of Princess for lillibet do
you think and that's obviously uh the
little boy as well he's also
um a princess Alfie I can't remember his
name anyway uh he's going to be a prince
Archie there you go thank you
um tweet me at Cape early and we will
read out your comments on the Telly
should they take the titles of prince
and princess after everything they've
said about the royal family here in the
UK treat me directly if you would like
to at K Burley and we will share some of
your comments with the world a little
bit later on now though for some more
exclusive news to bring you from our
Westminster accounts series Boris
Johnson is still making a significant
amount of money six months after walking
out of number 10 in fact the former
prime minister's earnings make up 85 of
all of the outside earnings generated by
all of the other MPS this year some
coats has more
the most famous face in British politics
this week's six months since Boris
Johnson was forced to leave number 10.
in resignation he promised the nation
there were good times ahead even if
things can sometimes seem dark now
our future together is golden for him it
certainly has been here are the MPS who
have declared the most in outside
earnings so far in this Parliament and
at the top it's not even close nearly
five million pounds in earnings for
Boris Johnson almost all of that earned
in the six short months since he
departed Downing Street
and 22 million pounds now that's the
total amount of money all 650 MPS have
declared on top of their 84 000 pounds a
year salary since the last election in
December 2019 and here are the MPS that
have registered the most in outside
income so far in 2023 so we've got the
data for just under two months of
earnings now understandably many of
these numbers are quite small but one
man clearly is having a very good year
financially at least the former prime
minister has registered over 3.7 million
pounds in extra income just since the
third of the year he's been paid over
500 000 pounds by publisher Harper
Collins for a book that's yet to be
published a nearly two and a half
million pounds from an agency which the
former prime minister describes as an
advance for speaking engagements now the
sheer scale of Boris Johnson's earnings
are really rather extraordinary so look
at this 4.4 million pounds is the total
sum of outside earnings made by all 650
MPS so far in 2023 and of that figure
Boris Johnson alone has earned 85 of the
cash
a highly paid speaking gigs have spanned
Singapore New York and Mumbai and now
Westminster not Parliament this a
conference just down the road Boris
Johnson giving his first public reaction
to Richie's next brexit deal what just
happens to be a very lucrative platform
Boris Johnson how much are they paying
you to pronounce at the brand Finance
conference why aren't you doing this in
Parliament
Uxbridge in West London is where Boris
Johnson has made his political home this
is not a safe seat some constituents far
from Happy do you think he should stand
again and if you if he did would you
vote for him
um
oh I don't think I'd vote for him again
um he's making a lot of money like you
say doing other things so yeah step down
I'm okay with that but I wanted him to
focus more on his constituency I'm here
working six days a week but I never see
him being slung out of office by his own
party doesn't appear to have dented
Boris Johnson's earning power but is
this the golden future he dreamed of Sam
Coates Sky News
five million quitting some will be here
in the next hour to tell us more about
what he's uncovered in the Westminster
account
you can find out more about the
Westminster accounts a joint project
between sky and tortoise media and use
our special online tool by visiting
skynews.com or on the Sky News app
scientists in Japan have managed to
create mice with two biological fathers
by generating eggs from male cells it's
a development that could open new
possibilities for reproduction for
same-sex couples Sam has been looking
into it for us good morning good morning
K world this really is a major
scientific breakthrough by those very
clever people at Osaka University in
Japan potentially Paving the way for
human male couples to have children now
it's a very complicated method but
essentially how it works in essence is
that they have found through research
that by converting male skin cells into
stem cells they're able to create eggs
now these eggs are then fertilized with
the sperm of another mouse creating mice
now in doing this process they have
created seven uh healthy mice they're
saying with a normal lifespan and this
process the scientists are saying could
also be used to help with certain
genetic conditions for example Turner
syndrome is something that they say
could be helped in the long term but the
scientists have also stressed that you
know this is something that they say
could potentially help human male
couples have children in the future but
this is something where there are still
many obstacles in the way and could
still take many years uh in the making
okay thanks very much indeed interesting
stuff though huh fantastic let's tell
you about the Alzheimer's Society they
have seen a start rise in visitors to
its website since the family of Bruce
Willis revealed he has dementia check
this out the Hollywood star was
confirmed to have been living with a
form of Dementia by his daughter last
month prompting more awareness around
the disease the family of Bruce Willis
posted this photo on Instagram sharing
his specific diagnosis fronto temporal
dementia around the time of the
announcement the chief executive of the
charity reported a 12 000 increase in
visitors to the site
and if you want to reach out for help
visit Alzheimer's dot org dot UK we'll
put that on a strap for you later on
Alzheimer's dot org there you go
Alzheimer's dot org dot UK
still to come on the program for you
this morning we'll tell you about a new
campaign to promote regular checks for
breast cancer
I'm joined by the shadow education
secretary Bridget Phillipson that coming
up in the eight o'clock hour
and I'll speak to an Egyptian
cardiologist who's now being funny for
money
also making news today after days of
protest George's ruling party has said
it's dropping a controversial bill on
foreign agents opponents claim it's
inspired by a similar Russian law and
represented an authoritarian shift in
the country protesters say it could
stifle media freedom and damage the
country's hopes of joining the EU last
night police fired water cannon and tear
gas grenades to disperse demonstrators
in the capital
three people have been arrested in
relation to the murder of L Edwards who
was shot outside a merseyside pub on
Christmas Eve merseyside police said a
man and a woman have been arrested on
suspicion of conspiracy to commit murder
and other was charged with possession of
a prohibited weapon 22 year old Connor
Chapman has already been charged with
the murder and due to go on trial in
June of this year
the security officer and an alleged
robber have been killed in a shootout at
an airport in Chile after what
authorities say was an attempted Heist
to steal more than 32 million dollars
the shootout took place on a Runway
after around 10 armed robbers attempted
to steal the cash which was being
unloaded from a plane from Miami
a man has been released on bail after he
was arrested over footage shot inside a
police Cordon on the day Nicola Bully's
body was found police said a 34 year old
from Worcestershire was questioned on
suspicious on suspicion of malicious
Communications offenses and perverting
the course of Justice
the government is announcing a new 29
million pound package of funding aimed
at tackling loneliness in disadvantaged
areas across England a quarter of adults
in the UK in the UK experience
loneliness as Alice reports
Pat is a hundred years old and widowed
her family live far away her disability
means even getting out of the flat is a
challenge my carer
took me last week
else in the chair and took me all around
the block and she's got permission from
her office to take me out every Friday
she said
for an you know to take me out and give
me a bit of fresh air because otherwise
I hadn't been out for two years
right here's your coffee pot
there you go
Lindsay volunteers with age UK and for
the last six years she's been visiting
Pat to keep her company I look forward
to it write it down Lindsay coming
is my day
well loneliness is often associated with
old age figures suggests that many feel
isolated particularly young people
a quarter of people in the UK feel
lonely
36 of 16 to 29 year olds experience
loneliness but only 16 of those over 70
experience loneliness
the government's new funding for
volunteers may go some way in tackling
loneliness but not everyone is convinced
until we can start looking at chronic
chronic loneliness as part of the mental
health Spectrum we're going to find that
actually this may put provision in place
and these initiatives May reach some
people but it may not tackle the
underlying issue and also the fact that
people are highly unlikely to put their
hand up and ask for support until it's
already too late
volunteers may not help everyone
struggling with loneliness but for
people like Pat they're invaluable
Alice Porter Sky News
the Oscars take place this Sunday but
most of the spotlight is on the actors
absent from this year's ceremony
next year the Oscars will introduce a
new set of criteria to ensure diversity
among nominees but this year's nominees
show there is still a lot of work to be
done there are no women nominated for
best director and only two black actors
nominated across all acting categories
but for the first time four Asian actors
have been nominated including Ki hoi
Kwan for his role in everything
everywhere all at once Sky News caught
up with his former co-star Martha
Plimpton she reflected on the success of
their film the Goonies and how she how
proud she is of her former co-star
well I'm certainly impressed by the fact
that it's really uh taken such a hold in
the popular culture and I don't think
any of expect any of us expected that it
it necessarily would
um when it came out I mean we all had an
extraordinary time filming it
um and you know I guess ultimately it
did change all of our lives really
um
no I mean it's it's wonderful I think
it's lovely and I'm especially excited
for key because I mean my gosh he's just
he's the dearest human being and and the
sweetest man and that he's experiencing
this uh wave of appreciation and love
from all over is just really lovely I'm
really excited and happy for him
trying to remember what TV program she's
in she's really really good at if you
know um send me a treat put me out in
misery at K Burley and we will have
exclusive coverage of the Oscars here on
Sky News from the red carpet in
Hollywood from seven o'clock on Sunday
and then we'll be live with all the
winners here on breakfast next Monday
growing speculation that a pay deal
could be reached by today as talks
between Health secretary Steve Barclay
and also representatives from three
unions draw to a close the NHS has been
hit by a series of strikes this winter
with the service already under severe
strain so let's speak to a former Health
secretary barity should we see what he
thinks former chair of the NHS
Confederation as well Stephen Doyle of
course great to see you thanks for
joining us did you miss the job yes of
course I miss it if you spend the bulk
of your life in politics uh you miss the
the buzz of politics and the most
important thing actually about being
Health secretary is the opportunity to
deliver high quality services that make
a real difference to people's lives and
just linking your first question to me
to your intro I think the central charge
against the way that the government has
handled this winter is that it's been
reacting all the way through we've been
promised for years a Workforce plan for
the Health Service which will which
should aim to turn it into a good
employer values its people and that's
the Gap it seems to me we should say
that you were conservative and now you
are a lib Dem so you're going to be
critical of the government but should
let me ask you this should nurses be a
special case
well I think ask me but ask most people
most of your viewers and indeed the
government itself during the pandemic
was telling us that NHS staff are
special so I I don't think you have to
regard them as Saints they're not Saints
but when Rishi sunak and Steve Barkley
took office in October they knew that
the Pres the Health Service was going to
be under huge pressure over the winter
periods it always is and it was going to
be particularly bad this year everybody
knew that but here we are still at the
beginning of March talking about the
terms that are going to apply in the
financial year that runs out in three
weeks time
the NHS gets a massive pot of money
every year from the government but it's
incredibly expensive department and
service to run it's never going to have
enough money no matter how much money
it's given that's it enough is a funny
word in that context it'll never be able
to do everything that's absolutely true
there are choices to be made
going back to your original question uh
the the language of politics is the
language of choice you do have to make
choices
one of the choices I would wish to see
as somebody who cares about the Health
Service is that those politically
responsible for it demonstrate by their
actions the importance they attach to
the Health Service being a good and
motivational employer that's able
because it's a good employer to deliver
good services to its patients do you
think that nurses and other healthcare
workers should get inflation busting pay
Rises this year would you give it to
them
what I what I think the government is
going to do and I think it's right that
it it does it is to give pay Rises that
reflect the fact that inflation has been
going through a very high is at very
high level currently there's projections
and hopes that it's going to come down I
think it will come down from current
levels but imagining that you can base
the pay levels for the current year on
inflation as it was 12 months ago has
always seemed to me to be for the birds
and the government could have accepted
that and had a proper discussion with
staff representatives from October
is it appropriate that a former prime
minister earns 5 million pounds in a
matter of just a few months and yet
still is entitled to get all sorts of
severance pay during his time in office
and the sort of money that he owns in
Parliament I think the issue in the
Boris Johnson case is is he still in
politics or is he in Show Business
that's a question for him and it's
implied by your question it's also
actually a question for other people if
he makes a speech to a commercial
audience rather than a speech to
Parliament about his reaction to the
Northern Ireland deal is should that be
headline news it's a private event for
which is being paid is he a public
figure or is he a private figure earning
uh earning good money because he has
high profile should he be making those
speeches in the House of Commons rather
than well if he wants to be taken
seriously as a contributor to the to
political debate the place where
political debate should take place is
the House of Commons of course that's
true okay it's good to see you thank you
very much for joining us thank you a
quick look at what's happening as far as
the weather's concerned for you now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
the wintry weather will bring some
disruption over the next few days
especially to Northern England but
Southern parts will turn milder too
sponsored by Qatar Airways
and this is something you don't see
every day in sunny California here we go
a thrill-seeking kayaker sliding off the
Rooftop in South Lake Tahoe in
California the snow had piled up over
the last last couple of days as a winter
storm brought blizzard conditions to the
area residents are still digging their
way out of their homes after they were
buried under several feet of snow it's
like a lot of fun though doesn't it and
with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at our climate calculator here you
go a lot of gas we're using at the
moment are coal into our coal output I
should say coal-fired power stations has
increased you'll know that two of them
have been fired up for the first time in
many years because of these freezing
temperatures and we are bringing in more
than seven percent of our power from
overseas at this bit's not working so
don't look at it
um let's have a look at other stuff for
you time for a look through some of the
photos that have caught our eye today
are you more of a Savory or sweet pie
kind of person well the British pie
Awards have taken place in
leicestershire with more than 900
entries ranging from Marmite pies to
balti pies with a classic Ponto favorite
beef and Ale also in the mix I love a
pork pie this week's freezing weather
couldn't get this group of swimmers out
of the water as they marked
International women's day at Portobello
beach in Edinburgh all in the name of
Charity good for you ladies and it
wasn't just humans bearing the the
elements animals actor whip snade Zoo so
a little flurry of snow as well that
tiger not sure what to make of it all he
looks a little bit happier about it
although doesn't he
now combat Kate
check this out in all the papers today
but the big question is can we have a
look at the picture
here we go what is wrong
with this picture from combat Kate
we'll tell you after the break
foreign
pictures from Buxton in Derbyshire this
morning the highest town in England as
many of you will know and it is
continuing to snow there today if you
are heading outside we'll bring you the
weather forecast shortly basically a lot
of snow up north not so much in the
South no snow at all here in London
despite the promises from the weatherman
or woman I should say that before the
break we asked you what's wrong with
this picture of uh Princess Kate
Princess of Wales there you go let's
have a look at it full frame and then
you can see it a bit easier okay this is
a picture that's in all the papers today
uh the Princess of Wales
um is um there and people are saying oh
what's wrong with the pig show she's not
going to help me so nope that's not it
we need to lose that strap guys
um what else is that she's not got a
bulletproof vest on nope it's not that
either look where she's put the
tourniquet
if you really had an injury in his leg
there and that tourniquet was put there
he would bleed out in two minutes we
know this because we have to do those
sort of courses here at Sky that is not
where you put a tourniquet you put it up
towards the thigh where you then try to
get the bleeding to stop there to say
our top story is for you this morning
Ukraine's zaparitzia nuclear power plant
which is under Russian control has lost
power supply due to what Ukraine says
has been a Russia Russian missile strike
forecasters are warning that parts of
the UK will see blizzards today as more
Arctic air flows across the UK
and Sky News has revealed how Boris
Johnson's shot to the top of the league
table for MP's side earnings this year
talking about that with Sam at the top
of the next hour meantime it's been
reported that former prime minister
Boris Johnson privately warned Dominic
Raab about his conduct when he held
several cabinet positions under Mr
Johnson's leadership the former PM is
understood to have provided evidence to
the independent lawyer looking into a
number of bullying complaints made by
senior civil servants against Mr Rob
let's get more on this Tamara standing
by hi tomorrow what are you hearing
morning Kate well this is the
long-running investigation into Dominic
Robb which has been going on since
November into claims of bullying now
it's reported by the telegraph today
that Boris Johnson raised Dominic rav's
Behavior with him and is giving evidence
to that inquiry so it's very unusual for
a former prime minister to give evidence
to an inquiry set up by Downing Street
and is being described by the newspaper
as a major development because it
suggests that there were concerns at the
very top of government about his
behavior now a spokesman for Boris
Johnson and indeed a spokesman for the
cabin office wouldn't comment on this
but Dominic Robb was of course foreign
secretary and then Justice secretary
under Boris Johnson it doesn't say from
what point these concerns date but when
Boris Johnson was Ill with covert it was
Dominic Robb who was stepping in to
effectively run the country at that time
and he is still the Deputy Prime
Minister now we think that that inquiry
is coming to a close Mr Robb has been
interviewed by the Barrister who's
running it Adam Tolley Casey and I
understand there aren't any more people
coming forward there are dozens who have
been reported to come forward Dominic
Robb of course told Sky News earlier
this month that if he was found to have
bullied anyone then he would resign okay
for now tomorrow thank you looking at
the papers for you know the guardian
reports EU officials have warned the
government's illegal migration bill will
be in breach of human rights law
the male speculates on the future of BBC
football presenter Gary lineker after he
criticized the bill
the telegraph leaks more of Matt
Hancock's messages this time suggesting
he was told to tone down a section of
his book about covid leaking from a lab
in China
and the Metro reports on Harry and Megan
christening their daughter lillibet with
her official titles
now any woman can get breast cancer men
too in fact so that's why it's important
to check your breasts regularly a new
campaign has been launched using a poem
and illustrations to help promote
regular checks and ensure people
understand the signs and symptoms of
breast cancer let's take a look
this is the way to examine your chest
topless in front of a mirror is best if
your breasts are fairly Hefty lift them
up righty Lefty have a snoop beneath
each one then turn to the side for a
look once that's done
you're looking for lumps on the surface
of the skin you're checking to see if
the nipples pulled in look out for a
puckering dimple or tether
now raise your arms up high together
this position may help reveal a bump or
lump your breasts conceal
well joining us now is the consultant
breast surgeon and two-time breast
cancer survivor Dr Liz o'riordan hello
to your doctor thank you for joining us
so tell me how all of this came about it
was some of the illustrations around as
we're chatting so I'm a breast surgeon
who's had breast cancer and handsome I
never check my breasts and I realize so
many of my patients didn't know how to
do so in lockdown I just put a video
online showing people and Laura Bradford
the poet behind this contacted me and
said I'm 37 and I didn't know this I
want to make a poem that's catchy that's
not scary
and she reached out to the incredible
artist LMA Statham who got women of all
shapes and sizes to come and act as
models just to create something that we
can help Every Woman check their breasts
and I've been blown away by the response
why do you think it is first of all that
women don't know how to do it and then
even if they did have an idea that a lot
of them just don't check their breasts
do they I mean I never did I was a
breast surgeon I thought it won't happen
to me I don't think we're taught at
schools you may see little videos online
but that's not how a breast surgeon does
it
my mum didn't tell me how to do it and I
just think especially when you're young
and you mammograms don't work it's the
one thing you have to pick up breast
cancer early and that's why we've
created this free resource to try and
help Every Woman learn what to do
although ultrasounds help a little bit
ultrasounds are great for lumps but
they're not great for screening the
whole breast and we don't that's why
young women don't get mammograms because
their breasts are too dense to see a
cancer okay so
um tell us what women should do
obviously we've got the illustrations
behind and where can we find this so at
the moment it's just on our Instagram
account and we're hoping that we can
create a website to share this all over
the world to get it translated just for
free you need to look at your breasts
you need to feel them you need to check
your armpit it's all in the poem and if
there's anything you're worried about
let your GP know when do you need to do
it if you have periods then you should
do it in the middle of your cycle when
your breasts are less lumpy if you
stopped having periods then pick a date
and a lot of people go for the first of
the month and is it once a month every
month I do when you're in the shower in
ideally when you're lying flat in bed
rest up in a couple of pillows
especially if you have large breasts
otherwise you're not feeling the breast
tissue and we talk about that in the
poem tell me what happened to you so I
was 40 I was a consultant breast surgeon
and I had a lump I ignored it my mum
said get it checked out and it was a
stage three breast cancer wow yeah stage
three stage three goodness and it came
back on my chest wall a couple of years
later which meant I had to retire so I
now spend my time doing this just to
help educate women when you say on your
chest wall difficult to feel it there I
thought it was a nodular scar tissue and
I'm a consultant breast surgeon and I
didn't know if you are if you find a
lump yeah what do you do it's really
scary and most women with lumps aren't
cancer but what I tell anyone to do is
go and see their GP they will refer you
into a breast clinic and they can do the
scans and hopefully put your mind at
ease yeah as you say most lumps are not
I mean I have had several lumps removed
thankfully none of them touch would have
been cancer but it it is scary it's very
sad and you didn't go even though you
found a lump why did you not go I just
thought it's not can so I've had tested
before I'm not worried about this when I
look the same and it was my mum who said
look I'm worried and she was right and
that fear of what if can be paralyzing
how did you get together with the lady
that wrote the poem and also how did you
then decide how to illustrate so Laura
Bradford who wrote it he lives in France
contacted me and said I've seen your
video I'm inspired I want to make
something that's not scary that's
accessible and her aunt to a secondary
breast cancer said there's potential in
this I'm going to pay for you to have it
Illustrated and Laura reached out to LMA
Statham who got women to send in
photographs of themselves of all shapes
and sizes so we can make it real and you
can find yourself in this poem and think
I can do this am I right in saying that
men can contract yes men do you get
breast cancer it's rare but it does
happen they also get mammograms and
we've had incredible men sharing it
yesterday even though it was
International women's day okay and as
far as men are concerned same things
apply but even more difficult to get
them to go to the doctor it's scary and
again being in a clinic full of women
it's not something that men normally
feel comfortable with especially when
breast cancer is mainly pink in the
media but if you notice bleeding on your
nipple you have a lump you should also
get it checked out and okay
um and how's your health now all clear
touchwood fantastic and great to hear
thank you very much explaining that to
us and we can find it on your Instagram
at the moment Instagram at the moment
and we're hoping someone will help us
get a resource so we can share it well
let's see what we can do about that
what's the Instagram
um I'm irid and Liz yeah and the author
is totally telling Tales that's Laura
Bradford's account so you can find it
when we clip this up for our Twitter
feed we'll make sure we say that as well
thank you very much thank you great to
see you thank you
no he didn't have to die those are the
words of a grieving sister as she
accused Scottish authorities of a
catalog of failings over her brother's
murder Alan Gettys was stabbed 40 times
hours after violent prisoner Stuart
Quinn was unexpectedly released from
jail conergyllis reports are you daddy's
boy Lucas Allen Geddes adored his son
Lucas a popular family man but he was
brutally murdered at the hands of Stuart
Quinn a violent serial criminal with a
history of psychotic outbursts
someone who'd been released from prison
here in the northeast of Scotland just
hours before he stabbed Alan 40 times
came out in court that he was he had
been shouting for his family that his
family would would help
and and that that that rings in my ears
and it breaks my heart Stuart Quinn's
released from prison that day it was
both unexpected and unplanned and it led
to him having a distressed state of mind
now a report sheds light on how the
authorities handled that release and it
paints a very Bleak picture it says that
he posed a risk of violence there was no
accommodation or care package put in
place and it concludes that that is
likely to have impacted the outcome
this report is a catalog of feelings
it's almost like we're enabling them to
go out there and do it because nobody's
nobody's doing anything about it
nobody's making a decision therefore
someone is either going to be hurt badly
or killed and your brother my brother
was the one that was killed yes this
report examines the Killer's
interactions with NHS mental health
teams in the 18 months leading up to the
murder it states aspects of that care
including how risks were assessed and
managed which have acted on might have
mitigated the risk of violence
systematic failures right across the
system it's quite clear that Stuart
Quinn should never have just been
released back into into society there
were gaps in the system to prepare
inmates for reintegration the process
suspended due to operational pressures
three months before Quinn was freed
authorities say an overhaul is coming
I'm angry now I'm angry that um
my brother would still have been here
that um
it was a it you know it was a it was a a
death that didn't have to take place
and my brother wouldn't have had to
suffer like he did the officials
involved have promised to learn lessons
Conor Gillis Sky News
back to our top story for you now
Russian missiles have struck cities
right across Ukraine including the
capital Kiev the Black Sea port of
Odessa and the Second City of kharkiv
the zaparitzia nuclear plant has lost
power it's the most um full forecast
um attacks since for the last three
weeks or something like that is what we
were hearing from Stuart joining us now
from Kiev is in a substance who is a
member of Ukraine's Parliament
representing the golos party hello to
you good to see you thanks for joining
us at the most intense for three weeks
of focusing on the capital as well tell
us what the latest situation situation
is where you are
well I'm in cave right now I woke up at
5 50 clear time because I heard the
explosion should be told they didn't
hear the air raid sirens over the night
so I literally woke up to the sounds of
the explosions and then there were two
more that I could hear of in clear and
then I started scrolling through the
news and I realized that the attack has
been on board for two hours by the
moment I woke up myself and attack
touched multiple cities all over Ukraine
Park Cuba on the east of Ukraine has
been here over 15 times then that also
towns and cities in western Ukraine in
Liberation region in the center of
Ukraine in the south in Odessa so it was
it was really massive there were lots of
a lot of missiles and drones that were
attacking the the country over the night
and we do know of at least three people
killed uh two of them at least two have
been killed in the residential house in
beverage I think that is the video that
the US show I don't know that was a
different one uh so so but at least
three people have been killed at least
two in Louisa which is on the west and
at least um one person in nepro petrovsk
region which is in the San Francisco
Ukraine
okay thank you very much indeed for the
update thank you
we this is the time of the program when
we do the happy birthday the team was
saying there's nobody famous whose
birthday was today I said hold me coat
this handsome fella check him out there
he goes that is my daddy he would have
been how handsome was my dad he would
have been at 91 uh today and he told me
to always have um a healthy disregard
for Authority there he is
um he said the impossible might take a
little bit longer that was something
that I've lived by ever since
um speaking of families I want to
actually I'll tell you about Eurovision
in a second because I want to bring in
these boys while we're talking uh about
family handsome chats all three of you
obviously Brothers Tom Max and Hugo tell
me your story
um and say when I was six I I went into
hospital with or went to see a doctor
with um you know I just had gastric flu
and it was all very routine
um and they did my they took my blood
pressure as a matter of course and it
was incredibly high so they thought the
machine was broken so then did it again
and again and um realized I had this
problem so rushed me to the hospital and
found out that I had chronic kidney
disease wow and I mean it wasn't a
problem back then I mean it was stage
three and sort of 75 kidney function so
actually it was fine
um and completely manageable and
actually most of my life you know I'm 31
now it's it it hasn't affected me at all
um but then it was about five years ago
I got sepsis
um after an operation uh which takes
such a toll on the body and it about
half my kidney function and then I got
it again last year
um and really dropped it to the point
where actually it's gone in it's
progressed to stage five now wow which
is when you but I need to do something
about it quite seriously yeah
talk to me yeah yeah well we all went to
get tested so myself bubs and my dad and
and my mother as well but she's not a
match so all three of us are which gives
us options
yeah Hugo is Bob's obviously because
he's the baby
you're the youngster so you you
um obviously have lived with your
brother's challenges as well and you
both uh are a match why should it be you
[Laughter]
um so we think actually we might go with
Max but our dad is also a match right
and so probably between those two
um and then hopefully you know this
kidney will last a long time but there
is a chance that Tom will probably need
another kidney so then hopefully that's
where I'll come in and then I'll be the
second transport then because they last
for about 25 years well they said I mean
it's amazing how far research has come
and kids kidney research UK uh you know
have have done a huge amount to the
point where it was only a few years
originally but now from a dead donor if
you take a kidney it's about eight to
ten years right but because I've got
these options because my brothers are
doing something so amazing you know it's
potentially 12 to 20. right some go on
for 30 40 50 years so it's more likely
that you'll need a couple you'll need to
line them up and they're lining us to
look forward to yeah yeah okay uh when
you heard that your brother needed a
kidney donut I'm sure you didn't even
hesitate but what was it like growing up
with him because obviously as you he's
younger you're younger than your brother
um yeah
what was it like I mean he was put very
poorly at times wasn't he he was very
poorly aged six but then I was 10 years
old so I was quite young yeah
um growing up it was never really an
issue because it just became the norm it
was on blood pressure pills on a daily
basis so it was more difficult for him
to get used to than it was for for us
really it was just
when he got sepsis and had to go to
hospital then it all became quite real
because then you realized that actually
something is quite wrong and something's
going to need to be done about it and do
you know when I'll come back to you
again in a second but do you know when
the op might be if you we don't yes
we're waiting to hear from Professor
Brown who's his his consultant and
he's got an appointment in April so
depending on the outcome of that yeah
yeah then we'll see whether it's in two
months time or six months time yeah and
Bob's it'll be your turn in about a
decade or so depending how things go you
don't mind calling you pubs hopefully
um yeah we do know someone who I think
it's lasted pretty much all their life
and that was from a dead kidney Dome um
and live condoners are supposed to last
a bit longer so fingers crossed won't be
for a while okay
um it's an amazing story what what do
you want people at home to know about I
mean is it can people be on registers
for this one yeah so I mean the key
thing is that that kidney disease
affects I think three and a half million
people in the UK and most people have
never heard of it and never thought it
would be a problem never really thought
much about the kidneys but but it's
amazing what an impact it has and and
how it can affect your life you know so
detrimentally so for me it was just a
routine blood pressure check otherwise I
could have had a stroke at any time uh I
probably shouldn't be here today
um so if you get a chance go to your
nearest pharmacy get a blood pressure
check for those who who really want to
do something incredible
um Nicola who's our live donor
coordinator is part of this scheme where
if neither of these neither none of my
family were matches you know they would
go on this kidney pairing register which
what they do is you know they would say
Max up with someone in Edinburgh it'd be
a match and then link it all together
and it's not uncommon for people to
actually donate a kidney to someone they
don't know to just contact their local
transplant unit
I can change someone's life yeah because
it takes your you know if you're on
dialysis you've got about five years
with a transplant you've got a future
okay we've only got 25 seconds
it was tell me quickly about that
I was hoping you weren't going to bring
that up actually uh yes we all have
matching tattoos on ankles I was worried
that you might share a picture of it
actually we have done yeah
we hadn't quite got that
I didn't realize good luck with the op
talk to us afterwards thanks for coming
in guys appreciate it in just a second
[Music]